j'ai vu la fin du monde
la mort était partout je n'ai ressenti
jean
ce n'était qu'un rêve
faux
/
j'ai eu bien des noms et autant
d'existence
ras krishna y avait
depuis que les mutants sont connus on
trouve des sectes qui voient en eux une
sorte de messie une présence divine elle
croit naître né il ya des dizaines de
milliers d'années
le tout premier des mutants
vous êtes tous mes enfants
vous êtes perdus
aux chefs sont aveugles
mais je suis là maintenant je suis là
pour vous il était toujours accompagné
de quatre disciples à qui est confié
certains pouvoirs comme les quatre
cavaliers de l'apocalypse d'appliquer ce
dans la bible ou c'est la bible qui lui
a piqué qu'est ce qu'il ya en dieu il
peut tous nous contrôler
charles
le monde a besoin des x men je suis
revenu pour ça pour me battre
on n'est pas tous capables de contrôler
nos pouvoirs lâche toi alors c'est la
guerre
tout ce qu'ils ont construit
c'est mon droit
et sur les cendres de l'art monde
ensemble nous en pâtiront un meilleur
je n'ai jamais ressenti autant de
pouvoir